là gì
option này là từ tiếng Anh dịch ra tiếng
anh ạ Bảo sao
Ờ
ch chào các bạn Ờ đang có một người xem
th
Alo ạ Alo ạ Ui bảy người xem rồi chào
các bạn có nghe các bạn nghe thấy rõ
mình nói gì không ạ Các bạn có nghe thấy
mình không
tí
ờ đợ đợi tôi một tí
Ờ Bây giờ tôi kéo cái này lên mấy ông có
nghe rõ hơn không nhá Mấy ông thử nghe
hộ tôi nhá Alo
alo rõ hơn nhiều không Alo Alo
Al
Alo
nghe rõ nhiều mà đúng
giảm xuống
này đúng là tính năng của
m cái cái vụ giảm xuống này
tôi có tiếng ngồn bên ngoài à Ok Để tôi
chỉnh cho độ mic nhạy của mic nó thắp
lại đỡ chưa
Ờ
đỡ hơn rồi đúng không nó còn bị tiếng
ngồn bên ngoài nữa không tiếng mic thu
Chắc là vẫn đủ rõ đúng không
Ờ tôi kể cho mấy ông vụ này cho ông nào
chưa biết về quả mác nó là tôi gọi bằng
mid gọi bằng
Messenger và nghe nói có cả bị về zoom
Đó là kiểu khi
mà kiểu dạng là khi mà mình gọi các thứ
thứ thế đúng không xong rồi mình dùng
cái mic mình nói to quá Cái này tự động
giảm xuống sợ vãi rồi rõ ràng là tôi đọc
ở trên đây tôi hôm trước tôi tra
m auto adjust Cái gì gì đó
đây input level các thứ thứ nó tự động
chỉnh lại cái tiếng của tôi nó bé lại
ý tiếng bé lại nên là tôi hôm trước phải
phải tham khảo đoạn này chạy cái đoạn
Script này này đây tôi vừa phải chạy cái
đoạn Script để mà tự động
à Cứ 1 phút thì nó sẽ tự động kiểu kéo
cái này lên cho tôi để tôi luôn được nói
to Bun cười vãy chưởng Nhưng có vẻ là
thằng mid Hay thằng zoom hay mấy cái
thằng gì gì đó ví dụ Skype này thì nó tự
động chỉnh lại chứ không phải bản thân
thằng m nó tự động chỉnh lại nghĩa là là
mấy ông hỏi cái này lên lên thằng ma lên
kiểu gọi là bên hỗ trợ của ma ấy Thì
người ta bảo là không phải lỗi của bên
nó nhưng có vẻ là tuy là không phải lỗi
bên nó nhưng mà nó lại cho mấy cái phần
mềm kia căn Hiệp vào nên thành ra là kể
cái input volume nó cứ tự động giảm ý và
nghe mấy ông này ở dưới Nói Skype có cái
kiểu vào option để cài đặt tắt nó đi
được nhưng mà thằng m thì tôi thấy có vẻ
không hề có cái đấy thành ra là tôi cứ
ngồi mò mãi không được này Skype có vào
này un check auto adj micro shifting này
đấy Kiểu kiểu thế này rồi đôi khi phải
phải disable nên kiểu config kiểu các
thứ
pancham là gì anh
thì tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ Ừ Chắc
là bây bây giờ có tôi đang định là tôi
sẽ chữa bài cho một ông nữa một ông cũng
đang cần chữa qua về cái đồ án gợi ý đồ
án cho ông đấy Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ tạm
chữa trước cho ông đấy X mình sẽ tập
trung code cái này nhưng mà có bạn họ
thì tôi tiện tôi trả lời luôn giới thiệu
qua luôn
thì mấy mấy mấy ông mà nghe tiếng bị nhỏ
hay mấy tiếng bị ồn tạp âm cái gì đó mấy
ông bảo tôi nhá Tôi đã đầu tư hết sức
hôm nay là đầu tư hết sức rồi đấy Hôm
nay cũng setting các thứ rồi cả tai nghe
cả mic các thứ thứ rồi cũng chuyên
nghiệp đấy Chẳng qua là không có camera
thôi à không phải không có mà tôi không
ý định là tôi sẽ quay
gì
Ờ cái này thì để giới thiệu qua van cham
thì tôi Thực ra tôi có bảo là bạn ấy gửi
cho tôi cái cái bản giới thiệu rồi nhưng
mà bạn ấy có vẻ chưa tự gửi cho tôi n
tôi cứ giới thiệu kiểu bình thường thôi
Nó là kiểu Nếu mà bạn xem tiêu đề thì nó
là trong web bán hàng bình thường đúng
không ạ
Ờ nhưng mà cái này là cũng là trong web
kiểu tâm H tâm huyết
tôi tôi đầu tiên là thực ra là sinh viên
của tôi làm làm thôi Nhận làm cái vụ này
thôi nhưng là tôi hỗ trợ cho bạn sinh
viên đấy bởi vì bạn Cả hai người đều là
người quen của tôi cả cái trang web này
chỉ là trang web bán hàng theo kiểu là
bán những cái đồ thủ công ấy đương nhiên
là bây giờ bạn mà xem Tôi demo tôi lấy
ảnh bên kumate thì phải hay cái gì gì đó
nữ cả về chúng tôi hay liên hệ hay cái
gì gì đó thì tôi copy của chat tbt ra
nhưng là đại khái thì đây là cái trang
Tôi định làm cho bên kia
là tôi hỗ trợ cho đứa sinh viên làm cho
bên
kia để bán hàng các thứ thứ thì thực ra
thì như hôm trước tôi có nói là tôi cũng
đang phân vân là không biết được là nên
demo code cho mấy ông về cái gì ý thì
tôi bảo là nếu mà làm cái phần mềm quản
lý của nhà trường nó khá là to cái là
việc là là kiểu nó ví dụ ở trường cũ của
tôi thì nó không cụ thể được cho trường
của mấy ông kiểu nó sẽ có cái bài toán
nó khác ấy nên là tôi nghĩ là cho dù cho
dù tôi khá là ghét làm trong g bán hàng
không biết tôi từng nói mấy ông có nhớ
không hiện tại Đúng là tôi V đang làm
công ty đúng ở trong web bán hàng nhưng
mà tôi không không động nhiều vào cái
nghiệp vụ bán mà tôi động nhiều vào
nghiệp vụ tôi thích là về database xong
rồi xong rồi thống kê xong rồi Hay tối
ưu nhưng mà còn nhưng mà bây giờ dù ghét
hay dù ghét hay thích thì tôi vẫn sẽ
demo cho mấy ông kiểu làm thử một cái
trang web giống như một cái đồ án một mà
tôi từng hướng dẫn mấy ông là làm trong
web bán hàng và tin tức thì nó sẽ như
nào Ờ nhưng bây giờ mình sẽ dùng là dùng
larel và kiến thức nó sẽ nâng cao hơn
một tí tôi sẽ tôi Tôi đang nghĩ nghĩ là
như thế Tôi sẽ đằng nào tôi cũng sẽ dạy
cho mấy ông kiểu dạng là tối thứ ba thứ
năm mà tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ dành luôn thời
gian đấy để làm con trang web này nên là
tôi sẽ nói chung là đây là một cái dự án
thực tế nghĩa là code của tôi toàn bộ
Cái này nó thực tế trừ với cái phần nhạy
cảm tôi sẽ có thể không không livestream
Ví dụ Giả sử liên quan đến ki bảo mật gì
gì đó nhưng mà còn đâu còn đâu Nói chung
ấy thì thực ra mấy ông sẽ được nhìn thấy
cái khá là khá là thực tế khi mà tôi
code thì nó sẽ như nào Tôi không tự tôi
không dám khẳng định là code của tôi
ngon hay Xịn gì gì đó nhá Bởi vì mấy ông
nhìn thấy
code đồ án chuyên sâu rồi thì mấy ông sẽ
thấy là thực ra nó cũng lởm lởm Bây giờ
tôi nhìn lại tôi cũng thấy chán lắm Nói
chung là trình mình cà ngày càng lên mà
nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi dạy mấy ông
không phải về larel không phải về mấy
cái kiểu code đấy mà mình tôi khi mà tôi
nói cho mấy ông thì mấy ông hiểu qua tư
duy cái luồng mà tôi đang code đúng
không Nói chung là mình kiểu dạng
là xem một người ta người ta code một
cái dự án thực tế Cứ cho là tôi cứ tự
nhận tôi là xio đi thì xem một xio code
thực tế thì người ta tư duy và người ta
xử lý cái bài toán như thế nào đúng
không Và tôi sẽ làm Bây giờ tôi thử nói
qua nhá tôi sẽ làm như cái
này larel Trung B en luôn ạ À đúng cái
này sẽ cả fen Và bend và thực ra cái này
C đang ôm cả jquery nhưng mà tôi tôi
ngại động vào view bây giờ nhưng mà hiện
tại dùng zer công nhận đểu thật tôi đang
cân nhắc là tôi Tôi không biết tôi còn
nên dùng laria mic không nhưng mà tôi
chưa động ở cái đấy bao giờ nên tôi có
khi là bây giờ nếu và động thì tôi đúng
kiểu ngồi mò trước mắt mấy ông luôn
Ờ thì tôi nói luồng nha Đợi đợi tôi một
tí tôi thử nói cái luồng mà tôi định làm
đầu tiên là đầu tiên là mấy ông có câu
hỏi thắc mắc gì thì mấy ông cứ vào link
này xong rồi điền câu hỏi thắc mắc gì
thì tôi sẽ hỏi ở bên này nhá
Ờ tôi sẽ đấy Hồi trước tôi định dạy cho
mấy ông tất cả đống này đúng không
Ờ Ừ Bây giờ cứ bỏ qua đi Bỏ qua hết toàn
bộ Mấy cái tài liệu các thứ thứ này vì
kiểu gì tôi cũng sẽ chia sẻ ở bên ở bên
kiểu dạng discord thì tôi sẽ kiểu nói
qua về Ví dụ ở đây à
À pancham này thì mình sẽ đầu tiên là
ôm tôi bản thân tôi vào động vào view ở
công ty là nó dùng luôn tôi còn chưa
cải đặt ngay từ đầu nghĩa là tôi vào lúc
mà nó đang gọi gian dở và tôi chỉ cốt
thêm vào nên là tôi không nắm rõ được
toàn bộ cái luồng của nó đâu nên là tôi
cũng khó mà dạy một cách bài bản cho mấy
ông được nên là bây giờ bảo tôi mò thì
tôi nghĩ là nó hơi xấu hổ một tí
Ờ đầu tiên
sẽ xử lý những cái gì thực ra là có
những cái
có có những cái mà bọn bọn tôi đã viết
tương đối rồi nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ thử đập đi làm lại thì nó không biết
có tốn nhiều thời gian không nhưng mà
tôi công nhận là tôi cũng hơi Ngơ Mắt
thật
Ờ tôi s sẽ tôi sẽ đầu tiên review lại
code
cái tổ chức
code sẽ kiểu sẽ hồi trước thì đúng là xử
lý hết nằm ở
controller
ờ nên là bây giờ tôi sẽ muốn kiểu code
nó sẽ dành mạch hơn nó sẽ nằm ở cái repo
x nằm ở Action cái gì gì đó xong rồi sử
dụng cái
obser đấy Mình sẽ có trong trong này sẽ
bao gồm những công nghệ
mà Đúng rồi Tiếp theo là obser này event
này event đi kèm với listener đúng
thứ thứ rồi còn trong El quầ có nhiều
lắm ví dụ chip
này hay là C cái gì gì
đó chắc là tôi sẽ liệt kê hết các công
nghệ trong này thậm chí là tôi sẽ muốn
liệt kê à muốn làm thêm là ví dụ là giả
sử là bạn ấy muốn muốn kiểu kết nối
thẳng sang
bên shopee chẳng hạn mấy cái api của
những cái thằng lớn Nghĩa là nghĩa là
chỉ là bạn ấy muốn tạo sản phẩm xong thì
sẽ tạo sản phẩm luôn ở trên shopee hoặc
là thậm chí là đơn ở bên shopee xong thì
sẽ đồng bộ về bên nên là đồng bộ hết một
chỗ về một nơi để bạn ấy quản lý thôi
mấy ông Hiểu không Chứ không phải đơn ở
Đơn đặt ở trên trang này xong rồi lại
phải sang bên shopee để check nghĩa là
bên shope một kiểu nghĩa là mình sẽ có
những kiểu api của shopee đi Giả sử thế
không biết được không nhưng mà tôi B
nhưng mà ý định của tôi là sẽ liên quan
đến cả những api của những cái bên trang
thương mại điện tử khác à Mình sẽ thử
làm thử thôi V cả thậm chí là còn liên
quan đến cả api cổng thanh toán
những cái mà liên quan đến key củng nhạy
cảm thì chắc là sẽ bỏ đi hả Dùng tool gì
để tạo domain à À đúng rồi bây giờ tiện
thể nói qua là tôi bây giờ Tí tôi sẽ đợi
tôi ừ bây giờ nói luôn nhỉ thì tôi bây
giờ tôi code thì vẫn bằng pp stor này
đúng không và dùng git Hub desktop chứ
tôi không không kiểu gõ git Hub được
luôn à Không gõ câu lệnh git
ờ
ờ Tôi dùng cái wap này cái wap này là
nghe nói là có tí ai và đúng là tôi thấy
nó đề xuất ra ha phết nhì này như này
chẳng hạn nó đề xuất đỉnh phết
biết nó miễn phí không Hình như là tôi
từng hỏn n Rồi mỗi tổi trả lời chán thôi
à đấy Ờ tôi dùng cả docker desktop Bây
giờ tôi dùng có dùng đer desktop để tôi
chạy môi trường để chạy được pp với cả
thêm mấy cái ví dụ Giả sử redit này xong
rồi Ờ
đây Credit này ngix này xong rồi về sau
có thể cài thêm vài cái nữa thì docker
nó hỗ trợ cho tôi đang cài lar
dog để chạy song song với được đc cơ đấy
thì
Ờ cái này về việc cài thì vài cái thì dễ
Còn riêng V dog nữ cả docker thì nói
thật là tôi nhờ anh leader công ty anh
cài cho nên tôi không
Tôi không biết là nên chia sẻ được mấy
ông kiểu gì vì tôi không biết ci
chung vào một công ty thì thường là
người ta cũng hỗ trợ mấy ông về độ cơ
lẫn cả đó cơ bản chất nó cũng chỉ môi
trường Thôi mà Thế nên là mấy ông có thể
nhiều mấy người đấy trợ
thì tôi thấy là là nó không hẳn là khó
hơn tôi thấy nó bằng nhau hết bây giờ
tôi quen dùng m rồi
Ờ nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là nó ở trên m
đúng chạy nhanh mượt hơn thật hồi trước
docker chạy ở CN con Windows tôi kiểu nó
C đơ nên là tôi hồi tôi Dùng Windows Tôi
không dùng docker luôn không biết là tôi
cày có gì nó đơ không biết mấy ông khác
như thế nào n tôi thì hồi tôi dùng thì
tôi vẫn còn dùng hồi tôi dạy mấy ông đây
tôi vẫn còn dùng lagon đúng không
vào danh sách đen rồi à Ông làm kiểu gì
đấy tôi Thực ra tôi đăng ký phải là ba
cái mailu với cái tài khoản này rồi giờ
vẫn chưa bị sao
Ờ nhưng mà naye nói là có bán qua
telegram à không quảng cáo gì đâu nhưng
mà hình như có bán qua đấy thì mấy ông
thể đặt
mua có docker tươ nhiên thay thể tốt chứ
bản chất là đ bản thân docker là kiểu nó
là tạo mình một môi trường ảo để mà mình
có thể code được trên đấy thì Dragon mản
chất là cũng thế thôi nhưng mà Dragon nó
không thể hỗ trợ tận ră bằng docker được
docker hỗ trợ được nhiều hơn
review lại code nhé Bây giờ tôi review
tôi muốn muốn đập đi làm lại nhiều thứ
lắm
tương đối rất nhiều thứ
rồi cho m ông xem thử nhá Bây giờ chạy
lại đầu tiên bây giờ lỗi bởi vì tôi nhớ
Tôi vừa xóa mấy cái đoạn code đi xong
tôi sẽ Tôi không biết tôi cài t Scope
chưa swit alert rồi tôi sẽ mở cho m ông
tôi sẽ cài thêm telescope
nhá telescope thì chúng ta sẽ code mình
sẽ luôn mở telescope kiểu gần như là
song xong để mà mình Mình biết được câu
truy vấn hay mọi thứ đang hoạt động như
nào để mình kiểu sửa
docker này xong
rồi van
cham rồi À cái này đé
code từ code cũng làm được cũng là tương
đối rồi tương đối rồi nó vẫn đểu nhưng
mà vẫn tương đối rồi thì bâ giờ Anh đang
muốn là kiểu chắc là mình động đến đâu
mình sửa dần đến đấy chứ Bây giờ mình
sửa hết thì xóa hết đi thì không ổn vì
bản chất là gọi như nào nh
Ờ không biết mấy ông có biết câu chuyện
đấy chưa câu chuyện mà kiểu Hồi trước có
một công ty nó đang trên đà kiểu đang
trên đà phát triển rất là ổn đang kiểu
kiểu dạng nằm trong top ấy sao tự nhiên
công ty đấy hai năm liền chẳng thay đổi
bất kỳ gì chẳng cầm nhật một cái gì mới
cả đấy Xong rồi khiến cho bao nhiêu đối
thủ cạnh tranh kiểu vượt mặt lên ấy xu
hóa ra hai năm sau nó tung ra một cái
phiên bản hoàn toàn mới nghĩa là trong
ha năm đấy nó quyết định một cái tá bạ
đập đi làm lãi hết đấy xong ng Cuối cùng
thì đươ nhiên là cái phiên bản Thứ hai
ra kia ít người đón nhận hơn và nó còn
lỗi tùm L và nó còn thiếu rất nhiều tính
năng so với phiên bản cũ thiếu tính năng
ở đây là bao gồm việc là Ừ thứ nhất là
thiếu tính năng bởi vì không làm kịp
được thứ hai là còn lỗi lỗi đây còn lỗi
cả những tính năng cũ tại sao Vì về sao
mấy ông sẽ nhận được cái giá trị đó là à
cái bài học Nó là kiểu những phần mềm
năng chạy ấ đôi khi nó không ghi lại
logic logic cái đoạn hoạt động ở những
cái tính năng mà nó gọi là tôi Bọn tôi ở
công ty được gọi là Legacy C code tức cả
những cái code kiểu dng là di sản những
cái code mà kiểu Ờ để lâu ấy Nhưng mà nó
hoạt động thì hãy để nguyên nó hoạt động
ấy bởi vì nó chữa rất nhiều cái logic
kiểu dị dị trong đấy rất nhiều cái kiểu
gọi là phải từng trải rồi người ta từng
fix từng trải rồi người ta để một cái
đoạn tạm bợ ở trong đấy để fix code để
nó hoạt động bây gi tự nhiên mình đập đi
làm lại mình lại không biết cái đoạn đấy
mình chỉ Ừ thì hồi trước mình có tính
năng a thì thôi Mình làm lại tính năng a
chứ mình không thể biết được là tính
năng a lại từng g bị gặp Cái lỗi này nên
phải có cái đoạn fix kia mình không ôm
cái đoạn phí đấy vào nên thành ra là về
sau mình lại đúng kiểu mình lại biến
thành một đứa trẻ chưa từng trải xong
mình lại phải chải lại từ đầu mấy ông
hình dung không đấy nên nó lại lỗi đấy
các thử thứ thực tế thực tế là khi mà
Mấy ông làm cái gì đó như thế đặc biệt
là bây giờ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông Ừ qu
Quyến mật quan trọng nhất không xếp tôi
chửi tôi mất quên mất vậ thì nó là test
đó Để tôi cài test
đã
đang cài là cái gì rồi đợi tôi mở code
lên xem đã tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông viết
test rất là cẩn thận Tại sao tự nhiên
nhắc nhớ vụ test bởi vì
đấy thì vừa rồi Tôi nói là kiểu làm đập
đi làm lại thế mế không phải giữ nguyên
cái test của cái cũ để mà cái cái test
đấy nó rất là quan trọng nó sẽ luôn kiểm
tra việc là là kiểu sản phẩm Ông có chạy
đúng chạy đủ mọi thứ hay
không đây tôi sẽ cài cái
này công ty tôi đang
dùng
chưa biết luôn hả thầy không ông ơi cái
này Tôi đặt tên tôi đặt ở trong cái
playlist là 5 đấy nghĩa là nó còn nâng
cao hơn cả mấy cái trước nên là cái này
gần như là kiến thức này là gần như là
dành cho mấy ông từ Junior đến senor chứ
không phải là kiến thức của fer hay là Ừ
Không phải fer đâu Không phải beginner
đâu
for Sun flash là gì
á không Chúng ta không dùng go chúng ta
không dùng chúng ta không dùng v cái kia
chúng ta code larel
mà chúng ta không dùng platform không
dùng pl
WordPress tôi vẫn khuyên mấy ông là mấy
ông nên học lập trình chứ không phải mấy
ông học mấy cái kia Thực ra nó là lập
trình nhưng mà tôi vẫn thường đánh giá
Nó là kiểu dạng như à th th đánh giá Nó
là kiểu dạng là kéo thả hơn không hoàn
toàn là lập trình không rèn được tư duy
nhiều qua một cái
đấy
ơ x debug của tôi lỗi thôi không sao
chắc cái này tôi sẽ cài sau
ư
Xem
Ok mình chưa viết test gì cả nên là bây
giờ nó lỗi tùm bây giờ lỗi tùm lum chắc
kiểu gì có khi bây giờ mình viết test nó
sẽ lỗi bao nhiêu luôn
các khóa trước đã Hả thầy Cái này là
Junio
đến xio Nên chắc là nếu mà Mấy ông fer
chắc là phải học từ khóa trước đây tôi
ghi chat rồii ghim lại không Đây
là
livestream
bạn biết
senor
ông cứ làm hồi trước tôi chỉ mấy ông làm
cái đ đ án một rồi mà Mấy ông làm xong
đồ án 1 đấy cũng tương đối gọi là Junio
rồi đấy ổi chư gì 30 phút rồi vãi chưởng
kiểu th anan Chu quan nhanh thật
Ờ nhưng mà trước khi trước khi hôm nay
tôi hôm nay thực ra là tôi cũng chưa
chắc là hôm nay sẽ code gì nhiều trang
này bởi vì tôi bảo tôi vẫn sẽ bảo là
chữa đồ án cho một bạn trước đã Thì hôm
nay chắc là vẫn chỉ mức tương đối giới
thiệu qua như này Ờ còn tí code được bao
nhiêu code vì tôi ý định là một video
bây giờ cũng sẽ chỉ hơn một tiếng một tí
thôi chứ không nên lâu quá còn nếu mà
lâu quá thì chắc là lần sau tôi sẽ phải
học cách gọi là bớt ăn bớt thời gian của
các bạn không thì các bạn sẽ nghe thì
chắc là nó không đ kiểu nó không ngắn
gọn xúc tích mà nó hơi dài dòng lan
man nên là Ừ bây giờ thì chắc là
bây giờ thì nó lại không còn nâng cao
nữa rồi Bây giờ nhảy qua hướng dẫn đ đồ
án cho bạn kia Ừ tôi sẽ lại bỏ pin cái
kia đi vậy
nhờ chữa đồ án tôi xin phép bạn đấy là
chữa chữa trên này rồi
đoạn I các web bán hàng á Chắc còn lâu
đấy không biết live biết Note js có được
không Tôi không biết trả lời câu nào câu
đấy như nào ông nghe ông hiểu thì được
thôi Ừ th Xem ào Xây dựng hệ thống quản
lý sinh viên ứng dụng điểm danh bằng
khuôn mặt cũng hay nhỉ Hồi trước tôi tôi
giới thiệu cho mấy ông luôn về cái vụ
Hồi trước là tôi định à Tôi định là
trường tôi là Định là một trong những
cái trường đầu tiên làm cái vụ điểm danh
khuôn mặt ấy chứ không phải là
là cái trường gì à đại họ thă Long à Ở
Hà Nội đâu Hồi đấy bọn Tôi Tôi định làm
rồi Tôi định dùng cái api của tháng này
của của Trung Quốc mà đương nhiên xịn
đặc biệt về mấy cái quả
ai nhận diện người ta checking các thứ
ghê mà đúng không Đây Face plus plus
Hình như hồi đấy nó cũng gọi là tính là
hồi đấy Open xộc và miễn phí tương đối
đấy Không biết bây giờ giá cả như nào
rồi
Xem api
miễn phí
nữa chuẩn bị thôi tạm
Thành
đấy api của nó miễn phí đấy Cho gọi một
ngày tầm mấy nghìn cái Có vẻ bây giờ nó
không còn miễn phí
nó tích hợp với cái phần mềm ở nhà
trường nữa thì nó sẽ tính ra Nó là một
trong những cái đầu tiên hiểu không điểm
danh và khuôn mặt chứ Hồi đấy tôi không
chơi Open ai không chơi đúng Open ai nhỉ
open CV à Open cái gì gì đó về cái ai
cũng nhận diện khuôn mặt cơ tôi không
chơi cái
sinh viên thêm sửa xóa môn học tạo lịch
học tạo ca thi Thế vẫn chưa đủ rồi thế
chưa đủ luôn nghe thế đủ biết chưa đủ à
Tại sao bởi vì
à Nếu mà cái này liên quan đến lớp này
liên quan
đến trường các thứ thứ thì bản chất bản
chất là các bạn sẽ phải thêm cả chương
trình đào tạo thêm cả Ừ Đấy thêm khóa
thêm lớp đâu khóa với lớp của tôi đâu
không có nghĩa là giảng viên nào cũng
dạy tất cả sinh viên sinh viên nào cũng
học tất cả các môn á đấy đủ biết là sai
đúng không
Đấy tạo lịch học Lịch học tôi cũng chưa
biết lịch học đấy dựa trên cái
gì
lịch học thường
là thường là một vài trường sẽ tạo lịch
học trường cũ của tôi không tạo địch học
trường tôi là à Trường tôi là kiểu học
kiểu CN chiếu rồi Kiểu Học hết môn này
nhảy sang môn kia x điểm danh thì điểm
danh theo từng môn chứ không có lịch học
kiểu dạng là hôm nay học môn này mấy giờ
các th thứ bởi vì lưu thấy lưu trong DB
cũng nhiều phết
đấy nên là không biết được bài toán bạn
ấy nếu mà mà bạn đấy làm theo cảo trường
Bình thường thì chắc phải lưu lại thêm
lịch học tạo ca thi à
Ừ thêm nữa
này cái này là ông nếu mà ông đặt tên
như th này thì nó sai với mất toàn bộ
mấy cái này rồi bởi vì như tôi vừa nói
phân tích ấ Thì cái phần điểm danh bằng
khuôn mặt của ông lại là cái bé bé bé
xíu luôn so với cái toàn bộ cái tính
năng quản lý một đống đống to kia hình
dung không Nghĩa là nghĩa là quản lý
sinh viên này quản lý lịch học này quản
lý s c qu C điểm này lịch dậy này th thứ
thì cái điểm danh của ông nó chỉ là một
cái k đặc biệt còn điểm danh bằng bằng
ai nữa còn Nó là kiểu bé của bé luôn
trong cái kiểu bức tranh to này
đấy Nên là nên là bạn này cần phải xem
lại nếu mà bạn ấy thực sự là chỉ muốn
làm mỗi cái tính năng điểm danh
thôi Bằng khuôn mặt thôi Cái gì gì đó
thì thực ra là bạn chỉ làm một cái kiểu
api để mà nhận cái ảnh của nhận ảnh vào
X rồi trên link cho nó để mà sau đó thì
xuất ra là kiểu ảnh này là thuộc người
nào có thứ thứ thế thôi không quan tâm
về việc là sinh viên nào thậm chí là
chụp chụp một ông nào đó kiểu chụp ông
giảng viên cũng được đấy chẳng hạn thế
nghĩa là cứ gửi ảnh cho nó thì nó sẽ trả
về kết quả thì đấy gọi điểm danh và
khuôn mặt đấy Kiểu như thế Cùng lắm là
trả về thông tin của sinh viên của những
cái thông tin sinh viên đã lưu đấy Thế
còn bây giờ nếu mà
còn còn để mà nói không thì thực ra là
cái này là bài toán là xây dựng quản lý
à Xây dựng hệ thống quản lý sinh viên
đấy chắc là bạn này muốn đặt tên như này
cho giật tít một tí thức là tôi thấy là
cái quản lý sinh viên nó đủ đủ to rồi ấ
không quan tâm về việc điểm danh khuôn
mặt
đâu Cái này kiểu giống kiểu sắc tanh lên
kêu gọi vốn không hiểu không kiểu
Ờ
kiểu cứ phải giật Tít có t ai các thứ
thứ
vào cứu
mất rồi
Ờ
chật vật với việc up code lên g h
á bé tra tra YouTube đi
bé và viết đúng chính giả nữa nhá bé nhá
ờ đăng ký học à đúng rồi dùng git
viên đăng ký học luôn
Uầy Nói chung là thực ra tôi chưa hình
dung Tôi muốn gọi bạn đấy để mà muốn xem
rõ là bạn đấy muốn Nghĩa là nghĩa là mấy
cái tính năng này bạn ấy đang ghi vẫn là
tính năng rất là chung chung không có
một yêu cầu đặc Tả cụ thể xem là trường
của bạn đấy hoạt động như thế nào như
tôi đã nói là Nếu giả sử trường này dạy
Giả sử dạng giống như là trường cũ của
tôi thì sao
trường cũ của tôi là dạy kiểu kiểu dạng
làm môn theo chương trình đào tạo rồi
Vân Vân hay là trường này là trường kiểu
Nếu giả sử mà trường này là trường kiểu
dạy chuyên chỉ một vài môn thôi là tất
cả sinh viên phải học tất cả môn đấy thì
sao nó khác nhau
mà còn cả đăng ký học như này nữa mà Cái
này chắc là giống kiểu đăng ký tín chỉ
của tôi tôi không học đại học như tôi
không rõ nhá Nhưng cái này chắc là tương
tự giống kiểu đăng ký tín chỉ nó sẽ lại
khác nhá Đấy đúng không Tôi có không
biết mấy cái vụ Tiến chỉ cơ Thật không
học đại học khá không biết m vụ Tiến chỉ
các thứ thứ như
bước này xa lắm bước này xa lắm Ông làm
xong đúng này chắc nếu mà nhanh thì chắc
phải 2 3 tháng Bởi vì ông còn viết cẩn
thận các thứ thứ nữa có phải viết cho có
đâu vì cái đoạn mấy cái đoạn trước là
mấy đoạn khá quan trọng mấy cái này tính
sau đi có DB rồi th xem
nào thế tôi nói qua DB nhá r Xem Ờ đấy
có lớp này kiểu gì cũng phải có lớp có
ngành này đúng không Thế cái tính năng
vừa rồi đây làm gì quản lý đâu quản lý
đâu ai là người quản lý ông ông ông code
ông tự nhảy vào ông tự thêm à cái này là
gì
nhỉ
khoa Công nghệ Khoa Khoa á ồ đây là Khoa
à Đây là ngành đây là Khoa vẫ chẳng hiểu
gì
cả
xem khoa Ơ có khoa thật này Ờ để xem
mấy ông thử nói tôi
với khoa
ngành ngành phải li quan đến khoa chứ
nhở đúng không ngành với khoa khác nhau
à tôi chưa hiểu cá này
nối đâu ông chém gió à đâu tôi thấy
ngành với khoa còn nối gì với nhau
đâu Hả mấy ông mấy ông đang xem mà gié
làm gì có tự nghĩ
thực tế nó đang như nào Nhưng ông này
không hề nối vào đ tôi thấy là ngành
riêng khoa riêng mà chẳng nối gì với
nhau cả nghĩa là chỉ là ngành công nghệ
ông tin có thể học khoa Thương mại đi tử
cũng được mà đúng không và ngược
Tôi thấy hai cái này có đâu liên quan vì
nhau
sinh viên lại theo ngành
h đấy Đấy ông ông tạo cái database này
ông mới bắt đầu lú rồi
thứ không hề nối với nhau này đúng
không
nếu mà ông không nối như này Lúc mà ông
chọn lúc mà ông chọn Là sao quản trị
viên lại nối với Khoa không quản trị
viên chẳng cần Phả nối bất kỳ thằng nào
cả hay quản trị viên là quản lý theo
từng khoa á Sao lại thế quản lý trị viên
Sao lại nối với lịch
nhưng mà ông ấy đang đi học ông ấy bảo
9:30 ông mới on được và ông ấy sẽ có thể
là xem lại livestream sau Nhưng mà như
mà Mấy ông đang thấy thực tế là nó đang
rất là loạn đúng không điểm môn học của
ông này đang nối với mỗi môn học này
điểm không cần nối V sinh viên luôn hiể
không đấy nhưng mà trong này có ID sinh
viên này có ID mô này Đấy đỉnh đỉnh
không nghĩa là cái thực thể này của bạn
ấy đang sai M mấy ông nhớ không tôi bảo
tôi bảo là chắc chắn mấy ông phải chữa
được cái thực thể được đã từ thự và cách
để làm ra thực thể chuẩn là bản thân là
ông phải làm cái cái phân tích yêu cầu
chuẩn đã rồi ông mới ra ở thực thể rồi
từ thực thể ra được database còn ông ấy
thì ông đấy
Viết yêu cầu là một chuyện đúng không
Xong rồi database ông ấy lại hực lên
thiết kế một kiểu xong rồi thực thể này
có khi thực thể ông làm sau cùng lại một
kiểu khác nên ông mới kiểu loạn hết cả
lên đúng không nên là kiểu mới có cái
kiểu thực thể nó sinh ra kiểu như này
Ờ nói chung là
cái tôi nghĩ là cái đoạn thực thể này bỏ
đi được rồi thực thể này nó cũng không
không còn đúng nữa Còn nếu mà dựa theo
DB như này tôi đang thấy khoa với ngành
Nó không hề liên quan đến nhau này môn
thì liên quan đến môn thì liên quan đến
Khoa
này sinh viên lại liên quan đến đến
ngành này xong
rồi giáo viên thì liên quan đến Khoa
này lớp thì liên quan đến giáo viên này
Nhưng mà lớp lại không có ngành
thì học lớp đấy học cái gì
viên liên quan đến khoa tức cả lớp đấy
chỉ liên quan đến khoa thôi Cái này liên
quan đến Khoa Thế cái ngành ở đâu rồi
ngành lại ở nằm trong sinh viên
h Uầy nghe
team tôi tôi dạy bây giờ cũng không hẳn
về tư cách j high team lắm nữa kiểu Hồi
trước là kế thừa bên J high school thôi
không phải là j high team dậy
đâu sinh viên ngành nào thì đúng nhưng
mà Mấy ông lại nói chung là mấy ông đang
bị kiểu quên mất khái niệm về thiết kế
về tôi Thứ nhất là tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông về
chuẩn hóa Lã nhá rồi về sau tôi sẽ dạy
mấy ông cách để bớt chuẩn hóa Tại sao
khái niệm bớt chuẩn hóa bớt chuẩn hóa là
kiểu để mình sẽ khái database flash Tức
là sao Nghĩa là nghĩa là mình thay vì
mình phải join rất nhiều bảng để biết
được sinh viên thuộc lớp nào thuộc khoa
nào chẳng hạn thế Thì mình sẽ mình sẽ
kiểu Mình sẽ lưu lại cái Khoa và cái
ngành và bảng sinh viên cũng được đấy
Kiểu như thế à Mình sẽ lưu lại vào trong
sinh viên code là để về sau mình đỡ phải
truy vấn sang join ra nhiều bảng đấy nên
thực tế
không Mình mình bản chất là mình vẫn
phải thiết kế xong được cái thực thể đã
thực thể B này đang sai thì tôi thử dựa
vào cái cái đây là tôi suy ra được cái
thực thể cho mấy ông nhá Thôi chữa lại
mấy ông cái này bạn đấy có vẻ đang loạn
hết cả lên rồi
mới dạy buổi này chữa cái này cho bạn
đấy đã cũng như là để mấy ông ôn lại mấy
ông thực tế là tôi dạy mấy ông vẫn đang
là gọi là đi logic lập trình viên từ đầu
đến cuối nghĩa là bao gồm phân tích xem
đề bài phân tích kiểu dạng các th thứ
xong rồi ra thực thể Xong rồi đến DB để
mấy ông về sau có thể nhảy sang nhiều
mảng không phải mỗi mảng lập trị trình
đúng không ạ vể lập trình đôi khi à Ông
Làm lập trình viên ông làm đép ông không
bao giờ động vào thiết kế cơ sở D liệu
đâu đặc biệt là vào công ty lớn đá
chuyện ông biết được DB ông có những cột
gì có những bảng gì Chịu ông không bao
giờ được can thiệp vào
đâu Đấy ông không biết được thực kiểu
sâu xa ở bài toán nhìn một cách khái
quát của bài toán là như th nào vì một
phần là bài khoán thể quá to DB quá to
nên ông nhìn vào ông lú rồi nhưng mà bây
giờ thì bài toán còn tương đối mức mức
này vẫn là mức jio thôi thì mấy ông phải
làm quen được mấy ông phải phân tích
được đấy thì bâ giờ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy
ông phân tích lại các thứ tôi thì tôi
cũng không khẳng định được là tôi kiểu
đủ chuyên môn hay là đủ kiến thức Bởi
tôi trượt tôi nhớ Tôi học đi học lại môn
cấu trức dữ liệu giải thuật ba lần liền
rồi nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ không
giảng cho mấy ông theo cậu toán theo
trong đấy được nhưng mà tôi nghĩa là tôi
sẽ có kinh nghiệm thực tế để tôi làm cái
mấy cái vụ này cho mấy
Mấy mấy cái về SQL chuyên sâu thì tôi có
một cái playlist riêng rồi ấ
Bây giờ mình sẽ lại lên draw.io thôi
phân tích nào tại sao bây giờ thỉ thoảng
bấm như th này nó không nhận diện đây là
trang web mà nhảy sáng Tìm kiếm
là quản lý sinh viên bắt trước bạn đi
quản lý sinh viên đấy bạn cũng ghi ở
Quản lý sinh viên mà đấy hay là ghi này
viết tắt à rõ ra bạn ấy C hiểu bản chất
là nó là quản lý sinh viên ít nhất là
như thế
ông có quen không như tôi có vẻ quen hơn
so Nhìn cái trắng tình này
Ờ mình sẽ đi từ cái thực thể con người
sẽ quản trị viên giảng viên sinh viên
đấy Mình sẽ luôn bài toán con người
trước
vội đâu Nó là phân tích kiểu dạng là ưu
cy à Tôi quên xừ Nó là cái gì
các bạn cũng sẽ được học môn này trên
trường còn không thì còn không thì như
đây quản trị viên Đúng không quản trị
giả viên giả viên gì gì đó đúng không
sinh
Ừ để xem lại nhá Đấy như tôi đã nói là
bạn ấy đi ngay từ đầu đã nhảy sang bên
giảng viên sinh viên rồi thì thấy là sai
mình đi từ gốc dễ đã Đầu tiên thì lúc mà
mới có trường thì đ nhên là mình sẽ phải
ở đây là trường nó sẽ phải có khoa mình
không làm đến nỗi quản lý cả trường
không phải quản lý nhiều trường nhưng m
như mà mình quản lý khoa quản lý ngành
quản lý
kiểu khóa nữa kiểu có khóa không nhỉ
Chắc là có mà đúng không mới không có
kiểu khóa hay khối gì không ch có mà
đúng không khối hay khóa của tôi
đâu khóa mấy khóa mấy đúng không là
có
đây khóa
chứ tất cả sinh viên ông Trung hết một
khóa không có khóa luôn Khoa
này ngành này cứ ghi hết ra đã nhá nganh
ngay Tôi đang để chữ hơi to nhưng mà đối
đối với mắt tôi tôi dạo này kiểu người
già rồi Như này mới nhìn
còn gì nhở
không
lớp s sinh viên đấy Ít nhất đến bây giờ
mới đến sinh viên đúng
không xong rồi giáo viên giáo viên thì
có đây rồi đúng không kệ giáo viên
đấy tính sau Ờ còn gì nhỉ Sinh viên so
đến Môn Đúng không muốn
học ghi hết toàn bộ ra đó
nghĩa đầu tiên là ông sẽ tạo khóa này à
đâu tạo khoa ngành g gì đó xong rồi tạo
khóa xong rồi lớp lớp đấy sẽ thuộc những
cái khoa ngành gì gì đó đúng không Ok
tức cả tức là rõ ràng lớp nằm dưới đúng
không lớp nằm dưới khoa vế ngành lớp
cũng thuộc khóa gì gì đó nối vào đấy nối
vào
đấy khoa với ngành Tôi nghĩ tôi vẫn đ đ
không phân biệt được khoa ví ngành cho
lắm đâu ông nào gợi ý tôi với
khoa
không Ok nãy giờ có vẻ mọi người đều nói
là Khoa lớn hơn ngành đúng không Ok
thông cảm không học đại học không không
biết điều này Ờ ok thì có phải là tôi cứ
bắt trước như mấy ông bảo đi thì có phải
là Khoa
sẽ khoa sẽ kiểu nối đếng ngảnh đúng
à môn thì chắc chắn là thuộc ngành đúng
không Bởi vì ngành bé hơn mà đúng không
Đấy môn ngành Nó đế Môn đấy khóa lớp ok
chưa để lên trên cụng
được đâ phải S đồ quan hệ
không nhưng mà tôi đang làm chưa đến sơ
đồ quan hệ nó bản chất là s thể đã sơ đồ
quan hệ mình có thể nối sau
ờ không biết môn có phải của Khoa hay
không ở trường cũ của tôi ấ thì chỉ phân
đến ngành nhưng mà một môn thuộc nhiều
ngành và một ngành có nhiều môn nghĩa là
nó là kiểu mối quan hệ kểu kiểu kiểu
kiểu n n chứ không phải hoàn toàn là
kiểu là ngành thuộc
à môn thuộc ngành đấy Kiểu
bạn này sẽ làm như th nào Nhưng chốc mắt
thì mình cứ để thế này đã chắc là chắc
là đợi khi là bạn ấy on bởi vì nó phụ
thuộc theo trường bạn đấy nữa rồi tính
tiếp bây giờ mình cứ làm mức tương đối
nó sẽ như này đúng không là kiểu môn
thuộc ngành cho nó dễ nó dễ thôi chứ nếu
mà để môn riêng xong rồi ngành môn có
thể thuộc nhiều ngành và ngược lại thì
nó lại cũng phức tạp hơn một tí đúng
không Nói chung là mối quan hệ nn nó
luôn phức tạp hơn mối quan hệ 1 n đúng
không
Ờ còn gì nhỉ
này không sao không nên làm này như thôi
tính sau à phân biệt theo r à Cũng được
xem ở đây sẽ còn bạn ấy muốn có đầu tiên
là Đầu Tiên Bây giờ các bạn cứ các bạn
khi phân tích này các bạn cứ hình dung
giống như vừa nãy tôi nói là cái gì có
trước cái gì có trước nghĩa là giả sử
khi bạn tạo ra một cái
trường bạn tạo ra một cái trường đúng
không Thì bạn sẽ tạo ra ngành khóa xong
rồi lớp xong rồi sinh viên xong rồi
Đương nhiên sinh viên sẽ đi học đúng
không đi học thì mình sẽ có điểm danh
sau rồi điểm danh đến một cái ngưỡng
nhất định thì mình m bắt đầu chấm điểm
và sinh viên đúng không đấy đúng chưa À
nghĩa là sẽ có điểm danh điểm danh thì
sẽ thường hay là điểm danh liên quan đến
giáo viên môn lớp bởi vì bạn điểm danh
cả lớp chứ không phải bạn và đươn nhiên
là trong lớp thì bạn điểm danh ch từng
bạn sinh viên một ngĩa là bản thân là
cái điểm danh này sẽ bao gồm thằng này
thằng này thằng này và thằng này đúng
không
thì mình sẽ thường là tôi sẽ tách riêng
ra hồi trước tôi từng vẽ mấy ông rồi thì
phải thường tách riêng ra kiểu như này
mình có một cái ở đây nên đặt tên nên
đặt nó một cái gì
thôi ở trước có một cái ô vuông đâu
đấy thôi không biết được nên để như nào
cho nó dễ hình dung bây giờ lấy tạm này
điểm danh này có phải thực thể hay không
cá nhân thì chuẩn nó sẽ không phải thực
thể vì thực thể là cái gì nó hiện hữu
Ờ nhưng mà nó sẽ có những cái thực nó sẽ
là ôm những cái thực thể khác Lúc mà
hành động một cái gì đó Đấy là giáo viên
điểm danh đúng không giáo
cho
đấy
lớp
theo từng ngày đúng không Hoặc là từng
buổi gì gì đó cho là vừa rồi bạn đấy K
đi đúng không Đấy chẳng hạn thế
ờ lớp Môn K và đương nhiên bản thân là
nó sẽ bao gồm cả
à một cái điểm danh này này một lần điểm
danh này sẽ điểm danh được
cho nhiều sinh
nó vừa nãy Ông kia bảo muốn mối quan hệ
đúng không đấy sẽ có mối quan hệ cho ông
đây đấy một lần điểm danh này này sẽ
điệm danh đề cho nhiều sinh viên
tích theo kiểu là là ông nhìn vào ông
nhìn vào cái này sa ông có thể vẽ ra
được cái thực thể này cái này chắc là
Dựa theo kinh nghiệm của tôi thôi đó là
biết được là một giáo viên khi điểm danh
thì mình điểm danh cho lớp môn K đúng
không C học C bao nhiêu C bao nhiêu đấy
bắt đầu từ mấy giờ bắt đầu từ ngày hôm
nào thường là theo lưu cả thời gian cụ
thể nữa nhưng mà theo K này chắc là cũng
được rồi vì bạn ấy nghe nói là bạn đấy
còn thêm cả vụ Lịch học cơ mà tôi không
biết lịch học bạn đấy lịch học Lịch học
chi tiết nà Uầy thế này mà ông kêu là
ông làm ứng dụng Điểm danh các thứ các
thứ mà tôi thấy là ông tạo bản Liên
không liên quan đến cái bên điểm danh
hơi
nhiều
thế tôi đang bỏ qua vụ lịch học đấy nhá
lịch học thì theo tôi nó sẽ phức tạp hơn
vì bản thân là ông sẽ phải có cái việc
là ông tạo lịch học đã đấy thức là ông
tạo lịch học nó n là giống cái bản điểm
danh mà thôi nghĩa là bao gồm tất cả
những cái thông tin này này xong rồi Lúc
mà điểm danh vào ông chỉ tích nốt là cái
kiểu lưu vào cùng một bảng cũng được ý
là tích nốt là sinh viên này cái lịch
học đấy có đi hay không cũng là một cách
nhưng mà điểm danh này có thể gộp chung
vào cái lịch học đấy cũng cũng được
đấy tiếp theo nhỉ Ờ Đấy này nối sang cho
nối sang này
đã nãy giờ mấy ông nghe có thấy thắc mắc
gì không
Không thực ra là mình còn phải linh hoạt
thường là một vài trường là linh hoạt
theo tuần ấy kiểu tuần này mới bắt đờ
tuần tuần này bắt đầu thông báo tuần sau
lịch như nào bởi vì
à
À bởi vì nó còn phụ thuộc vào lịch của
giáo viên rồi các thứ các thứ lịch thi
rồi các thứ thứ đủ kiểu nên là thường
hàng tuần nếu mà tôi tôi tôi không học
đại học nhưng mà tôi thấy nhiều đứa bạn
tôi thư ng thế kiểu được thông báo như
thế có tôi có một play list riêng về SQL
ấy SQL tâm huyết nhất tôi luôn không thể
xem cái cái đấy ủ Uầy tôi mới để ý cái
này có tận
à giật mình mình cái này là kiểu comment
lại ạ Ôi bạn này Thực ra làm cũng khá
tương đối kiểu chi tiết Ơ có tín chỉ này
Uầy B còn theo tín chỉ nữa thôi
thêm thì
có tôi không học đại học thôi học đâu á
Tôi học ở Cao đảo nghề thôi Ờ con gì nhỉ
Ừ khóa ngành lớp biên chế hả Có lớp bình
thường à Chắc không đâu đúng không không
hề nhắc lớp bình thường gì đây cả hai
lớp bên chế mới được điểm danh thôi chưa
hiểu lắm
Ờ điểm đúng rồi còn điểm này rồi Thi
đương nhiên là mình phải thi trước mình
tạo lịch thi trước rồi mới tạo điểm đúng
không hồi trước hồi trước tôi có cái vụ
này hồi trước tôi tôi định làm đây Bây
giờ tôi cứ làm cái vụ thi trước cho mấy
ông nhá Xô mấy ông thôi mấy ông sẽ hiểu
ì Tôi đang định muốn nói
à đây C cho đây à điểm danh nhá điểm
danh này đây sẽ thi đúng không
Đấy thi
này Đây là lịch thi tôi sẽ dùng rồi Đây
là lịch thi đi lịch thi mế không phải có
lịch thi đã đúng
không đấy thì đương nhiên là vẫn là giáo
viên lớp môn và thời gian thời gian thi
đúng không có thể theo K cũng được bởi
vì nãy giờ bạn ấy đang theo K
đấy thì tôi bản thân tôi cũng không dùng
bao giờ nó là chuyên sâu của eql server
và và nó không kẹo rộng của Trung về SQL
nên tôi không dạy
school Đúng không cái techable này nó
bắt trả phí không ạ Bây giờ ông đăng ký
trên đấy Bây giờ còn không được cơ nên
là bây giờ ông xem qua video rồi ông vào
discord để lấy bài tập rồi ông làm thôi
chứ hồi trước tôi tâm huyết của tôi bao
nhiều K Làm trắc nghiệm trên đấy rồi kểu
trắc nghiệm bẫy các bạn không được Bây
giờ nó gỡ xuống nó bắt phải trả phí ạ Mà
mình có thu tiền đâu về cơ bản lúc đầu
mình C không thu tiền giờ vẫn còn bắt
trả phí ạ Chịu
chuẩn là nó đang không có cả ngày Nếu mà
chuẩn là mình sẽ phải thêm ngày nữa
nhưng mà ở đây được rồi thôi tôi sẽ sửa
ở đây cho nó dễ đi nó là thời gian đi
thì nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ bao gồm cả k hay là
gì gì đó chắc thế Ở ở trường cũ của tôi
nó nó không có k đâu nhá trường cũ của
tôi lưu kiểu kiểu thời gian ấy kiểu tính
theo cả buổi luôn nghĩa là kiểu à Thi
mất luôn cả một buổi chứ không chuyện là
kiểu theo ca
lắm nhưng mà có thể là nếu mà làm theo
ca thì nó cũng sẽ linh hoạt linh hoạt ở
chỗ là hối trước vàở trường của tôi còn
về sau còn bị bế tắc cái quả mà quản lý
phòng học vì kiểu không biết được phòng
này bao giờ trống các th thứ thì đúng là
làm liên quan đến vụ Lịch học các thứ
thứ thì mình sẽ biết được là lớp này học
ca nào đúng không tại tại phòng nào các
thứ các thứ đấy để mình sẽ tối ưu về cái
phòng học rồi sinh viên cà ngày càng
đông thì mình sẽ không nắm rõ được là
phòng nào tại thời điểm nào nó trống
đúng không đấy thì cái đấy là con người
khó mà thể làm được Đấy lý do mà phải
cần phần mềm của các bạn mình Làm lập
trình làm phần mềm để nó tự động nó sẽ
kiểu hiển thị ra đề xuất ra những cái
kiểu dạng là là lớp này Hôm này thi lớp
này à phòng này hôm này trống đấy để
mình sẽ bố trí sắp xếp được thậm chí là
không phải người bố trí Hồi đấy tôi làm
tự động hết Tự động kiểu Ấn một nút cái
tự động chate tự động tạo ra thậm chí là
bọn tôi sẽ nhập thêm cả ngày lễ vào để
nó sẽ lọc ngày lễ này lọc ngày nghỉ này
đấy đúng không để nó sẽ đề xuất ra lấp
đầy được lớp nào cũng sẽ có thể học được
rất là linh hoạt đúng không cái này
người làm sao tính được để máy tính máy
sẽ tự động tính hết tất cả đấy Khi mà
các bạn Nhập đủ dữ điệu đấy đúng không
Nghe hấp dẫn đúng không như thế thì
chuẩn là cái môn này giống như là bạn
đấy phải có cả tín chỉ để biết được là
môn đấy bao giờ nó mới kết thúc để đề
xuất ra môn tiếp theo lấp đầy như th nào
chứ không thì sẽ bị kiểu tràn đúng
hacker rank á hacker rank tôi lên làm
vài bài có vài bài nó hơi bị gọi nhỉ
đúng kiểu là hacker ấy nĩ là người bình
thường chẳng ai làm thế C người bình
thường chẳng bao giờ kểu làm Mấy cái câu
truy vấn như thế cả thực tế không áp
dụng nên là nên là có vài cái tôi cũng
lịch khi đúng không đây tôi nhắc về vụ
lịch thi này một tí mấy ông nhìn Để ý kỹ
nhá cái phần lịch thi này này Thực tế là
ông hoàn toàn bởi vì ở đây sinh viên này
trong thời điểm này nhá là ông lưu lại
là sinh viên là được phép thi đúng không
Hồi đấy tôi còn định làm là ờ Nếu thế
thì tại sao mình lưu thêm một cái bảng
điểm làm gì đây tôi thử tôi thử cái đắp
l kết cái bảng lịch khi ra sang một cái
nữa là điểm cho mấy ông dễ hình dung nhá
chấm cho môn không có thời gian thôi
nhưng mà sinh cũng sẽ sinh viên kiểu này
và sinh viên đấy có điểm th lúc đấy Tôi
nghĩ là kiểu rõ ràng là lịch thi như này
thì biết được là sinh viên đấy
thi thi các thứ thứ đúng không thì hoàn
toàn đ biết được Kiểu chỉ cần thêm một
cột điểm vào là được à m rồi quên quên
quên quên quên đoạn này quên không Nói
mới nhớ đấy do cái phân tích của mấy ông
này của ông này sơ sải đấy mấy ông biết
đây tôi thử hỏi mấy ông xem mấy ông nãy
có tập trung hay mấy ông để ý không đố
mấy ông biết chỗ này thiếu thêm một cái
gì nữa
ngoài bởi vì tất cả mấy cái này bây giờ
nó sẽ là khóa chính nhá Nó sẽ là một lần
lịch thi sẽ thi cụ thể một lớp thôi thi
cụ thể môn và thời gian hay C gì đó mà
ngặc ca đây Đố mấy không biết Còn thiếu
cái gì
biệt được biết được lớp này môn này đã
thi hay chưa
đấy địa điểm thi Ừ cũng là một cái kiểu
phòng thi đúng không Nhưng mà ông đấy
không làm quản lý phòng nên thôi tạm bỏ
qua Ừ ông vừa rồi nói cũng một cái ý
cũng được ở công ty trường cũ của tôi nó
sẽ kiểu là lưu lại ở trong cái nốt đấy
Kiểu những cái chú thích ấy status á
status status thực ra không cần chuẩn là
theo thời gian đấy sẽ kiểu mặc định là
kiểu nó sẽ được bắt đầu và nó sẽ kết
thúc rồi không phải
status nhóm thi á nhóm thi là như nào
chưa hiểu Ý ông lắm ngày thi á Không
thời gian thời gian là có ngày rồi Giả
sử thời gian có ngày có k rồi Đấy cái
này cái này là tôi nghĩ là kiểu gì mấy
ông cũng sẽ từng gặp rồi
Thôi không phải điểm danh không phải
điểm điểm là nằm bên này chứ điểm nằm
bên này điểm tách biệt với điểm lịch khi
Tí tôi sẽ nói Tại sao nên tách
nhá Mấy ông Bao giờ thi lại
chưa hai trường không không cho thi lại
đ kiểu thi lần một tạch thì học lại
Đúng
á bọn tôi dưới năm là bọn tôi thi lại
rồi
chưa trả được rồi nó sẽ còn thêm một cái
nữa là lần
dung chứ lần có khi bạn không hiểu
giả sử Giả sử nhá Không biết trường mấy
ông như nào trường tôi thì cho theo lần
cơ nghĩa là khi lại lần hai lần ba còn
được chứ có một vai trường thì nó sẽ chỉ
bao gồm việc là đánh dấu là thi lần một
và thi lần một và thi lại thế thôi nghĩa
làm chỉ thi lại không được nữa thì tạch
học lại đấy có vài trường thậm chí là
không có thi lại đấy Ờ nhưng mà tôi nói
chung thì thường là nhiều trường sẽ có
chi hai ít nhất là hai lần đúng không
đấy
tại sao phải lưu lại lần thi bởi vì nó
đấy đấy là lý do là kiểu Tôi nói tôi
từng trải mà nó khác với việc kiểu mấy
ông là sinh viên mấy ông sẽ không để ý
việc là lưu datab có vụ lần thi đúng
không Nhưng mà chuẩn là các giáo vụ các
giáo viên sẽ phải quan tâm Điều này Tại
sao Bởi vì bởi vì kiểu sẽ phải biết được
là ví ví dụ nhá ví dụ nhá một cái Điển
hình ở trường tôi tôi phân tích cứ từ
trường tôi đã nhá tôi không bởi không
biết trường mấy ông nào mà đó là sinh
viên mà mà
nghỉ
quá quá 70 à không phải 70 nghỉ qua 30
ph số buổi đi học thì sẽ không được thi
lần 1 sẽ phải thi lần hai đấy đấy là một
cái đấy chưa và sinh viên mà điểm dưới
năm lần một sẽ được thi lần hai đúng
không Thì thì thế nên là lớp đấy sẽ luôn
thường là kiểm tra xem là lớp đấy lần
một thi và đỗ hết hay không Còn nếu mà
chưa đỗ thì đã có lần hai hay chưa để tổ
chức thi lần hai đấy phải dùng từ để tổ
chức thi lần hai nghĩa là phần mềm cũng
phải đề xuất việc là lớp đấy đã qua hết
môn này chưa Nếu mà chưa Thì lịch thi
lần hai đâu điểm lần hai đâu đấy đúng
không phần mềm chuẩn là phải tính hết
tất cả trường hợp đấy cho người dùng
đúng không Chứ không có
kiểu người dùng phải tự nhớ điều đấy
người dùng là sao nhớ được ngần đấy sinh
viên kiểu thằng này đã thi lại chưa lớp
này đã thi lại chưa đúng
không Thằng này đã được nhập điểm môn
thứ hai chưa Làm sao biết được Làm sao
kiểm soát được đúng không phần mềm mình
mình chuẩn phần mềm là là phần mềm xịn
là người dùng nhập vào những cái gì mà
người dùng biết thôi và phần mềm sẽ đề
xuất những cái phần còn lại
phần mềm sẽ đề xuất là kiểu ô mày chưa
nhập điểm lần hai thằng này này để biết
đường mà nhập đấy Thằng này đang đang
chưa được thi lần một này có đề xuất cho
nó thi lại không thậm chí là trường cũ
của tôi nó còn làm th kiểu là bởi vì là
kiểu tự nhiên có mỗi một ông thi lại môn
này ở trong lớp này đấy thì sẽ đề xuất
là cho nó thi cùng lớp khác được không
để đỡ phải tự nhiên mình nó một mình nó
một lần thi x đúng không Đấy gộp lại các
thứ thứ đấy Ông tôi đang nói tôi đang
phân tích cho mấy ông để mấy ông thấy
được là góc nhìn của người làm phần mềm
nó phải như thế nó phải phải kiểu cũng
gọi là cũng gọi là đi khảo sát để biết
được là thực sự là thực tế thực tế người
dùng cần những cái gì như thế đúng không
đấy thế nên ông mới bắt đầu bây giờ mấy
ông sẽ thấy sợ cái phần mềm đồ án T tôi
làm cho nhà trường tôi hồi trước nó
hoành tráng như nà đúng không Ngồi Phân
tích kỹ mấy cái đoạn đấy lắm chứ mấy ông
làm như này đúng là chỉ mức Junio Thôi
ngồi phân tích kiểu kia thì mức Junio
thôi làm sao mà đi khoe đi làm thực tế
được đúng
không đi làm Thực tế ông ốp Mấy cái phần
mềm này đi làm thực tế không không không
không khả thi đúng không người ta sẽ
dùng từ không khả thi Bởi vì nó có thực
tế đâu đấy mới không phải đi khảo sát
thực tế cần những cái gì m ông phải ghi
lại cái phân tích này một cách chi tiết
hơn để mẹ ông ra được cái database nó hỗ
trợ được cái điều đấy chứ như tôi đã
từng nói hạn chế hạn chế sửa database
nhất có thể không có chuyện là mấy ông
đang code giở mấy ông tự nhiên thấy
database thiếu cái trường này th mới ông
thêm vào đúng không thì thành buồn cười
Đúng không mấy ông phải Ngay từ lúc đầu
mấy ông phải xây cái database cũng tương
đối không thể nói là hoàn thiện hoàn
toàn được nhưng cũng phải tương đối dạng
là có vẻ giải quyết được nhu cầu đầu của
bài toán rồi đúng không Đấy th cái vụ
lần thi này cũng khác này bởi vì nếu mà
ông giả sử cho ba này khóa chính đúng
không Thì lớp này thi xong rồi coi như
là thôi không cho thi lần hai luôn kiểu
mày thi lần một tạch Hoặc là mày không
được thi lần một thôi học lại thế không
được đúng không Đấy mình sẽ phải thêm
cái lần thi này nữa đấy và tiếp về vụ
điểm vụ điểm này như ông vừa thấy tôi
phân tích thì nó cũng có cái lần đấy nó
cũng có cái lần ở đây như
này Đấy Bây giờ ông hiểu tại sao tôi bảo
nó khá giống v cái bên lịch khi không
Chẳng qua không Mỗi thời gian
thôi đúng
không Nhưng mà thực tế lúc đầu Hồi trước
tôi nghĩ nó nối bên lịch thi ổn hơn có
cả thời gian nghĩa là biết được là thằng
này lần thi đấy Nó được bao nhiêu điểm
đấy Kiểu thế nhưng mà cuối cùng thì về
sau tôi mới biết là lý do tại sao tách
ra cái lịch khi này với
điểm bây giờ tôi thử hỏi mấy ông nhá
kiểu tương tác một tí cho vui mấy ông
thử đoán xem tại sao tôi lại tách cái
điểm với lần th lịch thi nó
10 điểm xung phong
là có khi là mấy ông treo rồi xong rồi
để tôi rô ngủ
Ờ xuống thằng 82 rồi Ừ chắc có vẻ là ba
ông rời cố trời rồi đâ m ông thử đoán
xem là tại sao tôi lại tách cái điểm ra
sau lịch thi thô rõ ràng hai thằng Khá
giống nhau chỉ khác nhau mỗi thời gian
tôi cần mấy ông trả lời m cần mấy ông
điểm danh làm
giá mình ở đây đâu mấy ông mấy ông tự
tin phát biểu mà được được thì mấy ông
sẽ càng hang hái về sau càng tự tin hơn
Còn nếu mà ông không được thì chẳng ai
chê cười cả tôi cả đời tôi đi học tôi
phát biểu liều Nhiều vãi đúng kiểu Sếp
tôi thường hay bảo tôi có máu liều à Thế
Thành là kiểu những khi mà được được à
Kiểu được Kiểu nói chung là nó đúng ý
mình sẽ càng thêm tự tin
đã thi rồi mới có điểm Ừ đúng nhưng mà
tôi đang nói là lịch thi rõ ràng có
trước đúng không điểm có sau thì tại sao
mình không gộp chung lịch thi với điểm
luôn vì đằng ạ mình đỡ phải sinh ra một
cái hẳn một cái bảng nữa thì mình lưu rõ
ràng là kiểu gì chẳng thi rồi có điểm
đúng
tại trong một khoảng thời gian thôi Chắc
thế Không không không giả sử bài toán ở
đây mình không nói về việc là mình xóa
cái gì đó đi Phúc Hảo còn sửa Phúc Hảo
sửa thì cũng chẳng ảnh hưởng gì cả Không
sửa điểm đâu mà mà ông sửa lịch thi gì
đâu điểm có nhiều điểm à không điểm
nhiều điểm thì ông sẽ phân biệt qua lần
thôi Ừ đúng đấy là một cái đấy nghĩa là
ông chỉ là À không nhưng mà ông kiểu gì
ông chẳng thi thì ông mới có điểm đúng
không điểm bản chất nó có nhiều nhưng mà
nó vẫn theo lớp môn và theo sinh viên
rồi mà đúng
không sửa điểm không cần lịch thi được
bạn kia nói có vẻ gần đúng rồi đấy không
phải là sửa mà thêm điểm không cần không
cần lịch thi đ chuẩn nhất sửa điểm không
cần sửa lịch thi thực ra là tôi đọc kỹ
lại thực ra là ông kia nói không chuẩn
lắm sửa điểm đúng là ngay thời điểm là
hiện tại nó không liên quan đến lịch thi
rồi nghĩa là thêm một cột điểm đây thì
đúng là không nó tách biệt nhá lịch thi
và lịch thi chi tiết đây sẽ là lịch thi
chi tiết này chẳng hạn thì sửa sinh viên
thì đúng nó không lên qu lịch thi nhưng
mà đây để tôi nói nhé đó
là Ờ bây
giờ khi mà ông sinh ra cái phần mềm này
này đúng
không Thực tế là khi ông sinh ra phân
mềm này là các trường nó đang hoạt động
rồi chứ không phải Trường nó mới bắt đầu
mở ra xong rồi phần mềm ông ra đời luôn
ngay tại thời điểm trược mở đúng không à
Tức là sao hồi mà tôi làm phần mềm này
trường tôi đã hoạt động từ lâu rồi đúng
không Hoạt động từ lâu rồi người dùng
vẫn có thể nhập
vào nhập vào những cái gì nhập vào sinh
viên nhập
vào giáo viên nhập vào môn nhập vào
ngành như bình thường đúng không trước
đấy người ta có thể bỏ qua điểm danh vì
điểm danh của mình vẫn đang độc lập với
lịch thi đúng không và điểm cũng thế
người dùng muốn nhập điểm để làm gì
người dùng nhập điểm cho sinh viên thì
phải nhập chứ đúng không để mà về sau
còn xuất bảng điểm cho sinh viên thì thì
tự nhiên là bây giờ nếu mà trườngng đang
hoạt động rồi trường có điểm sinh viên
rồi trường có thể không cần nhập vào
lịch thi và điểm danh nhưng vẫn muốn
nhập điểm cho sinh viên đấy bài toán nó
nằm ở đấy đấy
đấy nghĩa là bản thân là trường đang
hoạt động rồi trường có điểm trường chỉ
muốn nhập điểm thì bỏ qua phần lịch thi
cũng được đấy do là đây là cái bảng tách
rời Hồi đấy là tôi cứ kiểu muốn kiểu Tôi
làm kiểu cũng kiểu muốn tối ưu các thứ
các thứ muốn kiểu rút gọn tôi kiểu muốn
kiểu lịch thi gộp chung với điểm thêm
một cột điểm đây là xong đúng không
Nhưng mà lúc đấy tôi phải tách ra như
thế đúng không Đó là là kiểu rõ ràng
trường đang hoạt động tự nhiên bây giờ
tao phải nhập lịch thi vào code để nhập
điểm V sinh viên à không đúng không Đấy
mình sẽ phải tách ra như thế để về sau
mình thống kê điểm ở sinh viên chẳng cần
thống kê lịch học hay là điiểm danh sinh
viên làm gì cả V sinh viên kiểu gì học
qua môn đấy rồi đúng không
đấy nghĩa Thế nên tôi mới nói ông bài
toán là khi thiết kế là một kiểu đúng
không mình phải nắm với cái kiểu bài
toán thực tế đã đúng không Bài toán thực
tế dị lắm Có nhiều cái dị lắm nên là nên
là mới cái kiểu nó mới phân biệt ra như
thế kiểu tự nhiên sinh ra một bảng riêng
rồi Cái thứ thứ thế x nghĩ rằng là mình
Thể Gục chung lại Không nó có lý do của
nó
đấy đấy thế nên là Nãy giờ tôi ngồi phân
tích cho mấy ông nãy giờ chỉ có liên
quan đến mỗi phần quản lý sinh viên thôi
còn chưa Đấy nhảy sang bên điểm danh
bằng ai các thứ thứ đã thấy phức tạp rồi
Đúng không mấy ông còn ngồi làm ai ai ấy
chỉ là con số nhỏ thôi Ông làm cái bài
toán này nó chuẩn đi đã Xong rồi Đề xuất
ra lịch thi này dựa theo điểm danh cho
chuẩn này ví dụ là giả sử là sinh viên
mà nghỉ quá Ngần này buổi chẳng hạn môn
học ông g tí tí chỉ đúng không Từ tín
chỉ của ông ra buổi không Nếu mà ra buổi
được thì tốt ông sẽ xuất ra được là
những sinh viên
nào phù hợp để được thi lần một đấy là
quá ngon rồi nghĩa là tại sao phải nói
ngon ở đây bởi vì nó là kiểu dạng là tôi
như tôi đã nói phần mềm của ông không
phải là một phần mềm Word không phải
phần mềm Excel nó một cái phần mềm lập
trình thì nó khác biệt với mấy cái kia
điểm gì nó khác biệt là khi người dùng
nhập vào nó sẽ phải trả ra một cái gì đó
mà không phải đúng cái mà người dùng đã
nhập Nó bị buồn cười thế nhập word nhập
Excel nó cò hơn đúng không nhập vào một
kiểu nhưng nó phải phân tích Từ cái dữ
liệu đấy để đề xuất cho người dùng ví dụ
đấy nhập vào điểm danh Cứ nhập vào điểm
danh bình thường thôi x đề xất lịch thi
tôi Hồi đấy tôi làm phần mềm kiểu người
dùng chỉ bấm nick next next kiểu kiểu
Chắc chắn là toàn bộ Cái dưới nó hợp lý
rồi ấ nick next next đề xuất ra hết kiểu
như thế người dùng càng dùng phần mềm
không cần phải suy nghĩ người dùng càng
nhàn thì lương mình càng cao Ông hãy nhớ
cái chân lý đấy khi mà làm cái ngành này
não mình thì đúng là cũng phải vất vả
hơn đúng không Nhưng mà mình làm việc
lao động chế óc mà đúng không Mình sẽ
đánh đổi nó bằng đấy bằng Lương Bằng mọi
thứ đúng không người dùng cũng sẽ không
kiến nghị gì cả đúng không Hồi đấy tôi
còn làm cả vụ api liên quan đến Facebook
nhá Tôi tạo lịch khi xong tự động tự
động đăng lên mọi nhóm liên quan đến các
lớp đấy đương nhiên là tôi phải điền cả
ID của lớp nữa nhưng mà chính xác là
người dùng chỉ cần nhập link của
Facebook lớp thì cũng có ID rồi tôi lọc
r ra lấy ID của lớp x Tôi dùng api tự
động đăng lên mọi lớp thông báo kiểu
dằng là lần lần thi lần một môn này tại
thời gian như th này có những sinh viên
nào được thi những sinh viên nào bị cầm
thi đấy xong đấy ông ông hiểu không quá
xị xong rồi tự động gửi mail toàn bộ
sinh viên rồi giáo viên cc giáo viên nữa
đấy người dùng chỉ bấm nick next ni trên
một phần mềm thôi nó tự động làm hết
toàn bộ các thứ thứ kia đấy thì thế mới
gọi là xịn chứ đúng không m ông hiểu gì
T không làm phần mềm Tôi không biết là
tôi có tính là đang khoe khoang phần mềm
của tôi không nhưng mà Thứ nhất là tôi
không bán phần mềm m không mấy không L
không th Tính quảng cáo như tôi tôi đang
nói là Hồi đấy tôi làm cái đấy tôi vẫn
còn đang năm hai đấy
nhá Tôi vẫn còn đang ngồi mò và tôi ngồi
học mò học rất là nhiều đương nhiên là
cũng nhờ sự trữ giúp của thầy tôi người
định hướng của tôi người ngày nào cũng
gì tôi de like Uầy c c thấy rất là đáng
sợ luôn ng h cũng dí nhưng mà Đúng là
đúng là kiểu thầy dí Thế nên mới có ngày
hôm nay kiểu dí kiểu kinh
các thứ phân tích cho tôi cũng thầy phân
tích cho tôi database này xong rồi nói
cho tôi định hướng là phải cần làm tính
năng gì x rồi tôi Tôi cảm thấy là người
dùng tôi Cái quan trọng là tôi Hồi đấy
tôi khảo sát người dùng liên tục để tôi
biết được người dùng kiểu khi mà dùng
thấy kiểu có vấn đề gì về phần mềm th
tôi sẽ tôi sẽ phải cải thiện lại nó nên
Hồi đấy tôi rất thích rất thích về sau
làm cái ngành là product Manager tức cả
quản lý phần mềm à quản lý quản lý kiểu
gì quản lý sản phẩm đúng không Tức cả
mình sẽ mình sẽ kiểu
à Thực sự là khảo sát người dùng xem là
người dùng thực sự cần gì đấy để mình
làm ra được cái phần mềm kiểu nói chung
là trải nghiệm người dùng được tốt nhất
Đấy là mình liên quan đến điểm và điểm
danh ạ Còn cái gì nhỉ Ông ấy định làm
thêm cái gì ấy nhỉ Đấy còn chưa lên quo
lịch học nhá ui lịch học nữ nữa CN lịch
học này chưa liên quan đến việc đăng ký
này đăng ký tín chỉ
này tôi thấy là tôi cứ tạm dừng ở đây đã
vì tôi thấy là riêng cái đống này ông ấy
làm xong có khi hết sử thời gian trong
cái đồ án của ông ấy
rồi bởi vì tôi đã nói rồi từ cái lịch
thi đấy mề ông sẽ phải khi mà đề xuất ra
nhập điểm ấy mế không Hồi trước là tôi
làm cũng gọi là như nhở cũng linh hoạt
thôi nghĩa là kiểu chọn lớp chọn chọn
môn thì vẫn sẽ hiển thị ch tất cả các
sinh viên kèm điểm trong cái lần
đấy không biết tôi từng demo cho mấy ông
chưa nhỉ Tôi từng đo phần mềm của tôi
cho mấy ông chưa
nhỉ Nhiều ông ở đây có thể lần đầu chắc
là mấy ông không không biết Để hôm nào
tôi thử demo phần mềm của của tôi cho
mấy ông nhá Không biết có bị dính dính
gì không à đâu Nó là của mình mà chắc
không bị dính bản quyền đâu trường còn
chẳng trá tiền mình
mà nói chung là phần mềm tôi hồi đấy
nhiều cái lắm rất rất rất nhiều Tôi chưa
có khi tôi chưa demo hết đâu nhưng mà
mấy ông mấy ông xem xong mấy ông biết
được Hồi đấy tôi làm hơn 2 năm liền thì
nó có nhiều tính năng ạ Tôi không nghĩ
là tôi đã từng demo hết đâu Vì có nhiều
cái lắm code của đấy nhiều vãy chưởng
là muộn rồi cái việc thôi Chưa chuẩn bị
gì cả phải xem lại đoạn code các thứ thử
đấy Xong rồi mở
mấy câu hỏi về thông tin cá nhân thì ông
lên Facebook tôi xem nhá Ờ
Ừ đại khái nãy giờ chắc là ngồi chém gió
thế cũng được tiếng rưỡi rồi cũng nãy
giờ cũng chỉ chém gió thôi nãy gi đã
codt dòng code nà đâu nghe kiểu ci ng ci
ngựa xem hoa kiểu cũng chưa làm gì cả
nhưng mà tôi phân tích Thế Hy vọng một
tí nữa ông kia Ừ ông kia 9 rư rồi Có khi
ông này cũng chuẩn bị về on rồi đấy Ông
cần phải xem lại thử tôi phân tích và
tôi thử suy kiểu suy ra như thế cũng
chưa đầy đủ của cái trường của ông đâu
Chắc chắn rồi thì ông sẽ phải tự bổ sung
thêm và nói và nhắn lại để tôi chỉnh sửa
nốt cho và như tôi đã nói thì làm Tính
năng nào nó nên không chỉ là Word và
Excel mà kể nhập vào như nào in ra đúng
như thế thì người dùng không dùng phần
mềm của mình làm gì cả nó còn khó chịu
hơn người dùng còn lưu cái đấy ở trên
giấy hoặc lưu trên đấy trong Excel sẵn
rồi tự nhiên người ta dùng phần mềm của
ông làm gì đúng không dùng phần mềm của
ông là để đề xuất ra kiểu mình nhập ví
dụ bây giờ mình nhập điểm như này thì đề
xuất ra tôi hồi trước tôi có tính năng
này hiển thị hiển thị là kiểu những
những sinh viên nào chưa nhập điểm những
sinh viên nào đang thiếu điểm nghĩa nó
được thi lần một rồi Tại sao chưa nhập
điểm cho nó đúng không Đấy thậm chí là
vụ điểm danh này cũng có thể Hồi đấy tôi
làm cái vụ chăm sóc sinh viên mà nó để
xuất ra là kiểu sinh viên này nghỉ nhiều
này sinh viên này gần đây nghỉ liên tục
này kiểu nghỉ ba lần liên tục kiểu cũng
đã đề xuất ra rồi kiểu đấy Kiểu kiểu dí
nó đúng không phần mềm này để hỗ trợ cho
giá giáo vụ để mà dí sinh viên mà đấy
đúng không kiểu để để cho kiểu sát sao
quan tâm sinh viên hơn
đấy hiển thị ra số phụ huynh của nó này
gọi đi Đấy x gọi xong rồi nốt lại là gọi
đã gọi bao lần xong rồi nốt lại là buổi
hôm đấy Gọi đã bàn nhau về cái gì đấy
Kiểu Thế Hiển thị địa chỉ nhà nó bên
cạnh
nữa một phần là trữ cũ của tôi là chệ
hng tư mà kiểu rất quan tâm việc sát sao
với sinh viên để
để sinh sinh viên nghỉ là mình mất tiền
mà đúng không phải xa sao chứ ấy kiểu
thế nghĩa là nghĩa là như tôi vừa Phân
tích cũng là để đáp ứng đúng có nhu cầu
của trường cũ tôi vởi trường cũ tôi là
là liên quan đến kiểu kiểu cần sát sao
sinh viên Chắc là trường đại học thì
không xát sao thấy đâu bỏ qua tạm tính
năng đấy cũng phải đế xuất cảnh báo gì
đó lên chắc thế đấy Ông càng xát xo như
thế thì thì người dùng mới thực sự càng
thích phần mềm của ông Word Excel đ đo
làm những cái tính năng đấy đúng không
đấy thì phần mềm của ông mới gọi là có
có tí tôi đến bây giờ trường cũ tôi vẫn
đang dùng phần mềm tôi mà chẳng có hiện
tại chưa viết được cái phần mềm thay thế
thì nó kiểu cũng đã ôm quá nhiều Nhiệp
vụ rồi có rất nhiều Nhiệp vụ rất là dị
giống như K in ra bằng điểm xong rồi in
ra đủ thứ Cá thứ thứ nữa Rất là lng
hơn 1 tiếng rưỡi rồi mình không còn câu
hỏi gì không Tôi thấy nãy giờ kiểu lượng
người vào lượng người ra cũng liên tục
luôn lên xuống lên xuống lên xuống nhưng
mà thấy kiểu cũng chỉ có một vài ông
bình luận không biết là mấy ông cắm máy
kiểu ngồi nghe tôi kiểu trong giờ ăn cơm
à Hết giờ ăn cơm rồi Chắc là bây giờ
Biến anh giờ trước Bé Ngủ Ngon rồi
đấy treo máy để r ngủ rồi 10:00 đi ngủ
là
hả Đâu
livestream thấy đông người vào V trưởng
đâ CV ông
đâu gọi bạn kia đi anh
á th Chắc anh sẽ chữa
sau sẽ chữa riêng cho ông ấy sau
Ờ chắc ông ấy cũng ngại mà né
né Podcast uy tín á
thì B ở đây có kiểu du ngủ chúp bé ngủ
ngon đâu B Tây nãy giờ kiểu cũng gắt đấy
chứ À review thầm kín Á được thôi em
inbox riêng cho anh rồi anh sẽ review
cho em nhưng anh sẽ đăng công khai không
phải đăng công khai thông tin của em mà
đăng công khai kiểu cũng những cái lời
anh đã góp ý cho em đăng lên để cho các
bạn khác D kinh nghiệm thường là
điểm này không lưu điểm thành phần chỉ
lưu điểm thi á điểm thành phần à Ừ nhở ở
trường đại học có cái kiểu điểm thành
phần hay là điểm chuyên cần nhỉ
ừ nếu thế thì thực ra ông sẽ phải thêm
một cột à Nếu thế không theo lần được
nhỉ điểm trên cần này Các th thứ Nếu
không thì tôi nghĩ ông tách hẳn nhiều
cột ra Ví dụ Giả sử là tôi lưu cái lần
này bởi vì trường cũ của tôi thì có kiểu
chi được nhiều lần thậm chí là điểm lần
hai lần ba lần
bốn lần ba th căng lắm rồi Kiểu là lần
ba thôi kiểu mày thi chưa Thy đỗ thì
thội chông chước cho qua hoặc là đánh
trượt hẳn luôn cho học lại xong rồi khi
học lại thì ghi lại đè vào điểm lần một
chứ cũng không quá thì ông có thể tạo
thành kiểu hẳn mấy cột là kiểu lần một
lần hai kiểu thực ra lần đầu và thi lại
xong rồi điểm chuyên cần đấy Kiểu thế
thì nó sẽ Có ngần đấy cột chứ không phải
kiểu lần kiểu nhá này nữa đấy là một
à đúng không Nhìn Đông giống không Kid à
Chắc không giống lắm
rồi lúc định làm web bán hàng cuối cùng
ngồi chữa cho ông này cuối cùng hết sư
thời gian chứ để buổi sau
Ờ mấy ông hỏi thắc mắc thêm gì không
Không gì nghỉ nhá tạm nghỉ Hôm nay nói
chung là cũng chỉ tầm trong vòng một
tiếng thôi thì mình kiểu hạn chế kiểu
dài quá hôm qua hôm trước kiểu gì lấn
kiểu gì tâm sự tận hai tiếng
à em on rồi à Ừ chắc là để tí anh chữa
cho nhá em ngồi xem lại cái
cái video buổi hôm nay đã Hôm nay anh
cũng GP ý em khá nhiều đấy thì em có thể
xem lại hết đã sau em thấy thắc mắc cái
gì thì mình
Mình có thể gọi nói chuyện riêng sau nhé
ok Bây giờ thì mấy mấy ông không còn
thắc mắc gì thì mình cứ tạm nghỉ đã nhá
Có gì mấy ông còn thắc mắc thêm thì có
thể điền cái link link link để để điền
form ấy nhá Chào mấy ông